the gyro can experience also sometimes
people are inflamed and irritated and
that changes their personality and to
have a healthy body or healthy
microbiome and all the just a healthy
system it affects your personality and
probably I get your really healthy
you're in a good mood all the time
that's a good way of looking isn't that
weird
oh it's true though I'm always striving
for that because you know I I'm in
sometimes saying I'm in a good mood I'd
say most of the time I'm in a good mood
these days but I don't ever want to [ __ ]
with the bad mood but you know when you
got bipolar I'm bipolar amongst a
million other [ __ ] things
what is that mental illness than your
average bear remember yogi the bear
I do remember you're not more mental
illness and you can shake a stick at
yeah it was hard to live with it but
look what is bipolar exactly mean well
we we used to call it moody
haha yes swinging manic states right yes
we up and down yeah one minute you're
this next minute you're that but even
more protracted is like well you're in a
good mood for months and then it's that
you know where they say that straw that
broke the camel's back oh that's kind of
clue one that you might be bipolar
heizo in the back of the camel breaks
and you just let our rip if you can't
control it anymore
and things you didn't even think you
were holding back come out you know if
you don't have the right way of
processing emotion you know it's such
extremes and then you followed the
extremes through with action like go in
someplace and you know then having to go
with some other place it's terrifying
mental illness is really terrifying I
think maybe this whole thing is gonna
move me to start talking more honestly
about it because I think of all the
conversations in America that's the most
needed it's a very important
conversation and it's also very
important that we have empathy towards
people with mental health because we
have empathy towards people with other
ailments right if someone has liver
cancer we don't go oh fix your liver you
[ __ ] idiot yeah well you know why out
here getting sick but if you have mental
issues that affect
we communicate with people and we think
it's your fault like if you have a bad
knee
no one says why can't you run up the
hill you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah but but if
you have something wrong with your brain
we just assume it's your fault yeah it's
a real bad thing it's a bad habit that
people have particularly people that
don't have mental health I know they're
they're such bullies
well they don't understand that it could
happen to you it could happen to anybody
I mean like that but the bullying the
mentally ill is so much a part of what's
going on in our culture right now too
abandoning them and and just in the
streets well that's a giant problem I
just know no share actually brought it
up she was talking about I'm sure she
was talking about them talking about
immigration and discussing immigration
she goes that's fine and good but we
have 60,000 mentally ill homeless people
wandering through the streets of Los
Angeles alone 60,000 I mean that's a
good size small town and it's filled
filled with drug addicts and people with
psychotic breaks and all sorts of other
mental illness yes I met a kid the other
day I always talk to the mentally ill
because you know it's partly that
they're so uh oh I forget the words
Louie uses it you know he looks well
they're so disenfranchised and ignored
and they become invisible yes and then
they retreat totally into their
psychosis yes I said they can't be
reached so bright you always do on my
favor just to make eye contact and say
have a nice day or well you're doing
them a big healing favor but I met this
kid he was about 20 and in his eyes L
black that white of his eye and I'm like
what happened your eye he goes I got it
tattooed I go how did you possibly sit
and let them put tattoo needle in the
wider your eye nine hundred and [ __ ]
fifty thousand times and he goes because
I have a deep fear of anything going in
my eye I've always had that fear and so
this was my way to overcome it I go dude
you know cousin ruffling people when do
they start tattooing their eyeballs well
you really obsessive compulsive English
and you're trying to get over one fear
by you know running through the fear and
making it HAP
to you and a lot of us do that you know
I guess I may be in my psychosis I might
have had a fear of you know being a
symbol of so much to so many I think it
crumbled me they kept saying that they
kept trying to make me be a symbol of
something yeah and I guess I am I have
anything I just want to be a symbol for
you know good jokes there shouldn't be
no censorship on good jokes do you think
that like the pressure of Fame and of
stardom of stuff contributes to this
feeling that you you know you you worry
about the the role that you have you
know you worry about people being upset
at you you worry about it and almost
like it comes out from that oh can i
[ __ ] yeah I'm celebrating sober October
Roseanne so I very good can I have yours
sure okay what sweeter on a drag plenty
of wheat here good Jamie's not
celebrating sober October three years in
a row I know I like it I think it's good
it's good to cleanse out the old wipes
every now I've been sober for almost a
year off pot yeah
till recently wondering ones one drag is
good that's the right amount gives just
elevates you a little bit gives you a
little lift but uh I tied one on the day
before sober October with Sturgill
Simpson and I don't remember even what
we were talking about while we were
talking
[Applause]